November 8th 2016 was election day uh a
day of Triumph or tragedy depending on
who you ask and as you may recall
Hillary Clinton was going up against
Donald Trump if you can think back that
far you might remember that um back in
those days before Chinese style coid
lockdowns became a pretext for
transforming the entire system of
elections in this country people
actually you know went to the polls in
large numbers on Election Day they
didn't mail in their ballots or hand
them over to a political operative they
actually showed up and voted so that
morning a left Wing activist named
Christina Wong decided to play a
practical joke on all of these election
day voters she went on Twitter writing
quote hey Trump supporters skip poll
lines at election 2016 and text in your
vote text votes are legit or vote
tomorrow on super Wednesday Wong also
uploaded a video on Twitter telling
Trump supporters once again that
election day in reality was on November
9th which was a day later than the
actual election day
watch hey everybody this is Christina
and uh I'm coming out I'm a trump
supporter and I just want to remind all
my fellow Chinese Americans for Trump
people of color for Trump to vote vote
for Trump on Wednesday November 9th
really important day we're going to show
this country who boss and that's our man
Donald Trump so don't forget to vote
Donald Trump on November
9th now that video you just saw there is
still available on Christina Wong's
Twitter feed she has not taken it down
and watch watching that video it's clear
to any reasonable person that it's a
joke no Trump supporter is going to get
tricked by a random woman on Twitter
into thinking that election day is one
day later no one's going to be fooled
into thinking that they can text their
vote in anonymously for any candidate at
all and at any event if somehow a voter
did fall for Christina Wong's stick then
I mean honestly they're so stupid that
they shouldn't be voting anyway and that
could be why the doj never charged
Christina Wong with any crime at all she
was engaging in political satire or
trolling or mockery or whatever you want
to call it and whatever you do call it
it was protected by the First Amendment
obviously but if that's the case then
it's very hard in fact impossible to
justify the doj's approach to a
different person a man named Douglas
Mackey on social media Macky used the
online Alias of Ricky vaugh and exactly
one week before Christina Wong posted
her meme on Twitter Douglas Mackey
posted this meme uh and the image reads
avoid the line vote from home now
Douglas Mackey posted this image on
social media a full week before election
day and at the time he posted this on
his Twitter account uh Mackey's profile
picture depicted a man in a Maga hat
wearing a Bane mask so it was not
exactly a credible announcement about
the upcoming election nor was it trying
to be it's obviously a joke exactly the
same joke that Christina Wong told and
at the time everybody recognized this
more than four years went by and no one
said a word about it no harm no foul no
damage was done not an issue but then in
late January 2021 just a week after Joe
Biden was inaugurated and his handlers
took control of the federal government
at doj everything changed Douglas Mackey
was suddenly hit with federal charges as
New York Times reported Mackey was
accused of quote spreading
disinformation online that tricked
Democratic voters in in 2016 into trying
to cast their ballots by phone instead
of going to the polls the FED said that
Mackey had quote coordinated with
co-conspirators to spread memes on
Twitter falsely claiming that Hillary
Clinton's supporters could vote by
sending a text message to a specific
phone number now I want you to take a
moment to reflect on that phrase
coordinated with co-conspirators to
spread memes on Twitter msnbc's coverage
at the time was just as breathless
here's how they covered the crimes of
this dangerous memes spreading Edge Lord
watch a notorious Twitter troll was
arrested on federal charges of election
interference Douglas Mackey also known
by his online Alter Ego Ricky vaugh is
accused of a voter disinformation
campaign during the 2016 election the
arrest represents what could be a big
change in how the federal government
fights election interference NBC News
investigative reporter Brandy zrz joins
us now so Brandy first of all tell us
about the election disinformation
campaign that Mackey is accused of
orchestrating what did he allegedly
do so yeah Mackie is accused of having
used Twitter to um coordinate with other
trolls in these private spaces private
group chats one was called war room um
and he's accused of spreading
disinformation specifically that voters
could cast their ballots via social
media and text um this one was
specifically aimed at Black and Latino
voters you could tell because he used
memes with black people and ones written
in Spanish allegedly
now basically you know what this guy did
is what we're all really familiar with
from the Russian internet agency they
created fake posts they said that you
know in these posts that certain celebs
were on the Trump train for instance
right or they created fake advertising
campaigns for Hillary Clinton where they
were like um we're going to draft your
daughters into the Armed Forces um or
you know like we just said the lies
about when and where people can vote and
just like the Russian campaign we've
been saying forever there's a homegrown
altri disinformation campaign and it was
aimed at electing Donald
Trump so Douglas Mackey is using the
same tactics as Vladimir Putin this guy
with 50,000 Twitter followers along with
Vladimir Putin is the reason that Donald
Trump beat Hillary Clinton that's what
they're saying they don't even realize
how ridiculous any of this sounds or
they do realize and they don't care and
that's how determined they are to come
up with reasons why Hillary Clinton lost
the 2016 election something that they
still are grappling with what's funny
about that clip aside from the total
absurdity of the whole thing is that
this week NBC's disinformation reporters
just spent an entire day lying about a
hospital bombing in Gaza they told you
Israel bombed a hospital and killed 500
people when in reality it looks like
some terrorist in Gaza put a crater in a
parking lot the NBC disinformation
experts who lied about the incident are
the same people telling you they're very
concerned about a meme posted on Twitter
about the 2016
election so they're complete frauds as
usual at the same time however they are
effective the Biden de put Douglas
Mackey on trial more than a half decade
after his uh conspiring to spread memes
and they did it using the same law 18
USC section 241 that they're accusing
Donald Trump of violating this law makes
it criminal to engage in a conspiracy to
deprive Americans of their right to vote
and this was a law uh that Congress
passed to prevent the KKK from
intimidating blacks at the at the polls
um it it's uh you know not something
that you would think would apply to a
meme on
Twitter and now it's being used to jail
everyone from a former president to a
random guy with 50,000 Twitter followers
who posted a meme because they are
determined to crush political descent
whether it comes from Donald Trump or a
Twitter troll or anybody else everyone
here at the office loves the genu Cell
Dark Spot Corrector we talk about it all
the time you might be asking what this
product even does well if you have
sunspots dark spots discoloration or dry
skin genus cell's Dark Spot Corrector
will help those blemishes disappear
Kimberly from Youngstown Ohio says quote
my appearance has improved so much since
using genu cell I love all my genu cell
products and my skin looks younger now
it's your turn to feel like Kimberly but
hurry because this sale is ending very
soon a lot of young men right into my
show asking what they can do to meet
women who share their values and beliefs
while the answer is take care of your
ugly disgusting face take advantage of
Jus cell's most popular package which
includes the Beloved Dark Spot Corrector
this package also includes genu cell's
classic under eye treatment you get all
the products for almost 70% off Jus cell
is so confident in their products you
can try them for yourself completely
risk-free if you don't see immediate
results you get your money back so go to
jus.com Walsh start looking years even
decades younger tomorrow say hello to
the best skin you've ever had at jus.com
Walsh that's genucell.com
Walsh so how did macky's trial go as you
could probably guess it wasn't exactly a
fair and impartial proceeding for one
thing Joe Biden's prosecutors hid the
identity of a key witness in the case
this witness know as Mr microchip was
important because to prove that a
conspiracy exists you need at least two
people obviously so the feds needed Mr
microchip to testify that he had engaged
in a conspiracy with Mackey but in a
remarkable if predictable turn of events
the doj convinced a judge to keep Mr
microchip's identity under seal and
perhaps more importantly the doj also
convinced the judge to issue an order
preventing Mackey's attorneys from
cross-examining Mr microtrip about his
uh extensive dealings with the FBI which
dated back at least to the year
2018 in his Communications with the FBI
the witness reportedly acknowledge that
there was no grand scheme to sway
election results but none of that could
come into evidence it wasn't brought up
a trial wasn't allowed into the trial
the jury also wasn't allowed to hear
that Hillary Clinton's own staff didn't
think that any of Douglas Mackey's memes
mattered during the 2016
election on the other hand prosecutors
were more than welcome the question
Macky about his views on women's
suffrage his opinions on whether
immigrants should be allowed to vote all
of those opinions that have nothing to
do with the case were allowed to come
into evidence to rile up the jury in in
uh New York and here's another important
point to keep in mind this is maybe the
most important Point prosecutors never
produced a single piece of evidence to
prove that a single vote was actually
lost due to Mackey's
meme the the jur did not hear from a
single witness who testified that they
texted they text their vote and then
didn't vote for real because of it there
were people who text the number because
they were curious about it or they or
whatever they were playing along with a
joke but there was no evidence or any
reason to believe that any actual real
world harm was caused by this
meme not that preventing idiots from
voting would actually be harmful in my
opinion that would be a great Public
Service I think but the point is that
there's no evidence at all that such a
thing
happened if he was trying to trick
people it didn't work nothing happened
there was no harm
done and yet predictably macki was
convicted and the other day he was just
sentenced by this federal judge to seven
months in federal prison for a
meme seven months that's the punishment
for mocking Hillary Clinton voters with
a meme which is essentially you know a
modern-day political cartoon
it it is the equivalent of someone being
put in prison for a political
cartoon and to put that in context a 7
months is longer a longer prison stint
than a BLM rioter received in 2020 for
threatening to murder a police officer
with an
AR-15 that officer was guarding a
courthouse that the riers were setting
on fire but this rior named Dakota means
was sentenced to probation meaning no
time in prison whatsoever Dakota means
by the way went on to murder his infant
child
now as horrifying as that story is there
there are many more like it pretty much
every BLM terrorist from 2020 received a
lighter sentence than Douglas Mackey did
for posting a
meme and most of them received no
sentence at all and were never even
charged with
anything and that tells us a couple of
things first of all it tells us that we
are led by tyrants and if there's one
thing tyrants despise more than anything
else it's being mocked you know you
could disagree with them and and most of
the time they'll shrug and and bury you
with an avalanche of their own
propaganda but if you mock them I mean
that's really how you incur their wrath
and they will go to tremendous lengths
years after the fact to make sure you're
destroyed for it the devil cannot endure
to be mocked as Thomas Moore said and
neither can the current regime running
our
country which and those two things are
certainly related the other lesson from
the Douglas Mackey case is that it's a
symptom of much larger problem Douglas
Mackey um uh could only be convicted in
a country that no longer cares about
basic principles of democracy which of
course includes the freedom of speech
and indeed it's becoming clear that our
country no longer cares about any of
those principles as Yahoo just reported
quote a large portion of Americans on
both sides of the aisle favor getting
rid of democracy and imposing violence
on their political opponents among other
authoritarian measures according to a
new poll 31% of Donald Trump supporters
and 24% of President Joe Biden
supporters said democracy is no longer
viable and an alternative system should
be tried according to an October poll
from the University of Virginia's Center
for
politics now poll results like this
aren't surprising because every day we
see new examples of the desparate
unequal application of the laws in this
country the other day pramas protesters
stormed a Senate Office Building
demanding a ceasefire in the Middle East
and they obstructed lawmakers on their
way to work they prevented media reports
from taking place it was an Insurrection
here's what it looked
like
[Applause]
now what we know for sure not that I
have a crystal ball but if but you know
I can still look into the future and
prophesy that not a single one of those
riers will be placed in solitary
confinement by Joe Biden's doj they're
not going to face 20-year prison
sentences just like the women who
stormed capital buildings during the
Kavanaugh hearings uh none of these
pramas degenerates will face any con
quence whatsoever and that's because
they didn't mock the people in power
they didn't put their feet up on Nancy
Pelosi's desk they didn't smile while
parading Pelosi lect turn around the
Capitol building so in the eyes of the
Biden doj they're not a
threat this ad hoc system of law
enforcement has gone on for so long that
a critical mass of Americans have lost
faith in our system entirely and why
shouldn't they lose faith in it what is
there to have faith in the appearance of
legitimacy as well as actual legitimacy
is non-existent in our judicial system I
mean 50 years ago jailing a political
cartoonist would have been Unthinkable
in a supposedly free
country yet it it just happened in this
country and the response has been
basically a collective shrug republicans
in Congress haven't come out in defense
of Douglas Mackey in fact I'm not aware
of a single elected Republican who has
said anything about this and maybe there
have been a couple I you know it's it's
I don't keep track of every single one
of
them but just ask yourself that how many
elected Republicans have come out to say
anything about the fact that Biden's doj
just put someone in jail in federal
prison for seven months for an
anti-hillary Clinton
meme for the most part there has been no
outrage from either
party so Douglas Mackey will serve his
sentence for mocking his Masters he'll
report to federal prison for his
memes
and because no one stood up in his
defense the fear is that very soon he'll
have a lot of company hey YouTube thanks
for listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there